Do you make the same commitment that you will
absolutely- sir- that you will absolutely
accept the result of this election.
I will look at it at the time.
It's rigged.
That's just not right.
I mean, this is a fair- first of all the election
is a state by state issue, so to think that
some sort of conspiracy exists that elections
can be rigged that's just- that's not good
for the system, when in fact it's not happening.
During all the debates we had like four minutes
tonight spent on the deficit.
For minutes out of all the debates!
And then there were really just a couple of
minutes spent on the entitlements, medicaid,
medicare, social security.
When these are really really huge issues and
not mentioned once were drugs.
Not mentioned once was the legalization of
marijuana and the fact that the number one
category of arrest in this country in the
last year is marijuana related.
That, that is flabbergasting and of course
completely missing.
Yeah, economics was a big part of the last
part of the debate tonight,
what did you think about all that?
Well, Hillary, there's a certainty that Hillary
is going to raise taxes uh there is a certainty
when it comes to Trump that there is uncertainty.
I mean he's talking about economic growth,
well you can't count on economic growth you've
gotta actually cut government.
That's the one thing you couldn't count on.
When he talks about restricting immigration
that's gonna have a negative impact on the
economy so, you know, I think Trump's toast.
There are a lot of leaks from Wikileaks, emails
and the like, about the Clinton campaign.
What do you think about the leaks that have
happened so far?
You know I wish they would be receiving the
attention that they deserve.
But I'm afraid that Trump and his continued
foibles seem to take up the airwaves.
Look, when Hillary Clinton says one thing
in front of wall street and says another thing
in front of main street, that's hypocrisy.
How's it feel to be watching the debates all-
all of the debates that have happened so far
and not being up there yourself?
Well uh I am on the ballot in all 50 states
so the only third party on the ballot in all 50 states.
I think that as a result of my campaign, the
Libertarian campaign this cycle, I think that
could change in the future and it's because
of the showing that we, that we have, that
we've demonstrated and that it'll be reflected
probably next election cycle.
If not still winning, I mean, all these revelations,
anything is possible and of course you have
no chance of winning if you're not in the
race.